une histoire incroyable franchement déjà
je te remercie énormément de m'inviter
ce soir parce que ça fait des mois des
mois des mois que je prends sur moi je
sais alors il y a Moundir aussi qui
m'avait compris
cette histoire il y a plein de potes il
y a plein d'humoriste plein
d'humoristement appelé très connu qui
m'ont dit cette affaire est inadmissible
alors en fait j'ai créé une marque de
stand-up qui s'appelle the joke Paris en
2017 avec moi
merci
calme-toi
parce que là c'est sérieux alors j'ai un
humoriste très connu qui vient de
m'écrire c'est super de recevoir
Yassine parce que c'est abusé ce qui a
fait Baptiste voilà donc tu vois il y a
pas mal de d'humoriste qui te
soutiennent alors et en fait j'ai créé
cette marque donc j'ai monté un plateau
qui s'appelle the joke comme j'ai dit
dans un bar qui s'appelle le fatbard
dans le 3e arrondissement on est en 2017
et mon frère qui est humoriste qui se
lance à l'époque anime photo et en fait
avec le temps ça commence à prendre au
début je les débuts sont difficiles et
puis je connais un succès assez rapide
franchement je vais pas te mentir et là
les humoristes passent le mot et je
reçois des humoristes de plus en plus
connus et en fait j'invite le fameux le
Kapla en 2018 et un message qui a testé
c'est moi qui l'invite sur mon plateau
il vient et il kiffe le plateau en fait
sur qui va le faire derrière bah
apparemment moi je m'y attendais pas et
du coup il fait il fait il fait il fait
son chaud puis après il revient il me
demande de revenir comme d'autres
humoristes voilà
moi je l'invite comme d'autres
humoristes Cyril j'ai pas tous les
contacts de la terre en fait j'ai moi
j'ai commencé à zéro en fait c'est ça
que les gens il faut qu'il comprenne
aussi et donc après il y a le covid donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe et après il y a
le covid et là pendant le covid le
public tu comprends il faut que ils ont
besoin de kiffer en fait et moi moi ce
que j'aime c'est faire plaisir aux gens
en fait créer du spectacle j'ai pris
goût à ça franchement j'étais pas sûr ça
et en fait j'ai une idée j'ai dit faut
que j'aille plus loin les artistes
aiment ma façon de travailler l'ambiance
qu'il y a dans la salle est incroyable
et après covid là tout le monde n'a pas
le moral je vais créer un Comedy Club
avec mon savoir-faire avec mon carnet
d'adresse que j'ai développé et on va
tout déchirer parce que voilà c'est un
milieu très compliqué le stand-up et moi
dans ma salle je veux qu'il y a une
[ __ ] de bonne ambiance quoi alors
Fabrice division
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez des
chances de gagner ou pas oui évidemment
parce que dans cette histoire il y a
d'autres trucs en fait moi alors je
connais Yassine depuis un moment je
pense pas m'aider de cette histoire au
départ mais je m'en mêle parce que bah à
un moment donné on a essayé de
l'impressionner on a dit je vais
t'envoyer les avocats d'Arthur voilà je
vais bon une espèce de truc comment ça
impressionner les gens tu vas voir je
vais te défoncer on va envoyer ça c'est
on m'a confirmé plusieurs à plusieurs
fois il l'a fait plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises en fait quand je commence à
ouvrir ma gueule
tu as voulu dire quoi bah genre en gros
je sais pas moi on parle d'Arthur mais
j'ai rien à voir avec Arthur c'est pas
non plus Chuck Norris
il me dit
chez les humoristes tout le monde
connaît l'histoire et je te le dis c'est
inadmissible cette histoire il a volé
les trucs vous êtes l'avocat depuis
combien de temps de l'avocat depuis
quelques semaines effectivement il y a
une voix quelques semaines
d'accord
dans le milieu des humoristes je pense
je le connais beaucoup plus que vous
tous les humoristes m'ont appelés
des semaines et des semaines que les
gens me disent bien sûr qu'on dépose
pourquoi il a pas été accepté parce que
c'était la même chose que en bémol n'a
pas voulu parce que ça allait c'était
votre logo oui mais quel est le rapport
avec la suite vous avez pas pu le
déposer parce que c'était le même logo
que en début d'année
c'est comme si jamais c'est comme
ici ce soir après on vous parlera merci
il y a un truc quand même c'est qu'en
fait dans cette histoire j'ai deux
problèmes ah il y en a on est sur un
plagiat non mais là là c'est juste parce
que vous êtes son avocat donc oui c'est
ça
évident ensuite deuxième élément évident
tout le monde le dit moi j'ai quand même
un problème c'est qu'on est comme le
définition qui te dit non il te dit non
bah si
c'est ton ami Moundir demande-lui vous
me dire je l'adore c'est mon super sur
l'affaire très bien et toi tu connais
qui toi dans l'histoire mais je connais
des gens aussi de les noms moi j'ai
donné des noms ben moi je le donne pas
Philippe Bouchardeau
avec les avocats de la partie adverse
toujours c'était pas maître division en
l'occurrence et les bonnes infos ma
chérie mais j'ai les textos j'ai tout
j'ai les mecs
je vais clarifier le débat de manière
très simple moi j'ai pas l'habitude de
faire dans la dentelle on se souvient
bien d'accord
[Musique]
vous avez un avis sur tout bien sûr
surtout non moi j'ai pas un avis j'ai
des pièces c'est pas la même chose tiens
quand je suis à chaque fois ou des
sources ou des pièces et quand j'entends
l'avocat j'ai des pièces et que donc
effectivement on va on va se battre avec
des pièces parce que vous imaginez bien
que c'est pas la version de l'un contre
la version de l'autre vous imaginez bien
qu'effectivement il y a eu des échanges
de mails il y a eu effectivement des
échanges de SMS
il y a trois procédures aussi pour
diffamation injures je crois voilà alors
juste Jean-Marie tu as entendu parler
cette affaire non non moi j'ai pas
tellement bien suivi donc je suis un
petit peu perdu là je les vois
s'engueuler
[Rires]
les poissons pourries je suis au courant
de rien donc
rappelle-nous l'histoire Yasin tu as
monté un truc juste et à Baptiste le
Caplain il y a la même chose sans te le
dire c'est tout en fait le truc à partir
en fait lui qui fait le le c'est bon
c'est bon
laisse les gens parler tu donneras on
donnera la parole et tu pourras pas pour
se défendre tout seul bien sûr ils vont
revenir
en tant qu'ami et il a pas du tout voulu
me donner une information il m'a dit que
lui pour lui il n'avait rien à se
reprocher et que ça se jouerait devant
on verra ça alors juste dire quelque
chose dans cette histoire en fait
Baptiste il me met moi c'est moi qui
suis allé vers eux mais pas l'inverse
c'est ça c'est très important c'est moi
qui est qui est proposé cette idée de
Comédie Club et lui il m'a mis en
relation avec son manager que je ne
connaissais pas monsieur ASLIM Smida il
est inconnu il était inconnu mais moi je
le connaissais pas alors que c'est
depuis 2017 que je travaille et ce
monsieur
c'est avec lui que j'établi une relation
alors on va faire ci on va faire ça il
me parle de ma fille mon dort voilà
pendant des semaines il me propose des
choses il me fait miroiter des trucs il
propose un projet à Arthur il y a un
dossier qui a été fait qui était proposé
Arthur ou je suis présenté dedans comme
le créateur de la marque le dirait futur
directeur c'est pas moi qui l'ai écrit
il a été transmis à Arthur Arthur a eu
accès à ce document et après à la fin
Baptiste à chaque fois je change de
question et l'esquiver il partait ah je
peux pas j'ai tourné j'ai truc ok il dit
qu'il a tout fait la déco le machin mais
c'est c'est dinguerie de Cyril donc il a
tout pris déco tout mais à la télé il y
a la presse il dit c'est moi la déco
c'est moi mais il a même pas choisi la
moquette
au départ il était censé s'associer la
société avec effectivement voilà et puis
finalement on a des échanges dans
lesquels au fond on s'aperçoit de quoi
c'est que progressivement de long en
long bah on lui dit ouais tu es la pièce
maîtresse sans toi c'est pas possible et
puis il y a le jour de l'inauguration
qui arrive avec la presse et là bah du
coup il se retrouve effectivement un peu
comme le balayeur ça j'aimerais bien
préciser une chose Cyril c'est très
important parce que pendant deux ans moi
je bosse franchement comme un ouf c'est
mon rêve là je réalise mon rêve vous
comprenez pas moi je viens de Metz c'est
un truc de fou pour moi et mon frère en
plus c'est l'humoriste ça veut dire que
pour moi je vais le mettre sur scène il
va avoir une un terrain pour jouer entre
guillemets et au final la soirée presse
elle a lieu un mois après l'ouverture
d'accord un mois ça veut dire une
voiture elle en avril le 11 mai je me
souviens de toute ma toute ma vie Cyril
il fait un discours il dit je vais faire
un discours de 10 minutes moi je sais
même pas au courant il fait un discours
de 10 minutes il y a Florence Foresti
dans la salle Jérémy Ferrari il y a des
gens je sais pas il me dit à Canal il y
a le Parisien il y a et bref il y a la
presse une soirée presse pendant toutes
les réunions il disait c'est moi qui
vais te présenter comme le cerveau du
projet celui le créateur parce que c'est
moi les humoristes le savent j'ai pas
besoin de mentir c'est pour ça que je me
suis pas esprit exprimé jusque là et ce
soir là il fait un discours il commence
il y a 17 ans j'ai rencontré un jeune
homme et parler de Baptiste le Caplain
ça veut dire que là il est facile du
storytelling mon frère et moi bien sûr
alors on détruit
honnêtement c'est déjà mentalement ça va
mieux parce que j'ai pris un vraiment
j'ai pris un mur 50 de travail et si en
plus un milieu qui marche beaucoup à la
confiance bien sûr mais surtout les
stars de les humoristes voilà s'il y a
beaucoup de requins du coup moi moi je
venais de messe avec mon homme voilà mon
insouciance et tout et j'ai appris j'ai
pris des coups ce que tu fais quoi
aujourd'hui bah j'ai la chance là je
vais organiser des plateaux parce que
voilà ça
je peux dire
alors moi je peux te proposer déjà c'est
peut-être que je vais avoir un lieu
bientôt voilà dans lequel je vais je
vais est-ce que tu veux venir faire des
plateaux chez moi avec grand plaisir
Cyril avec plaisir donc déjà tu feras
des plateaux chez moi tu vas remonter
des plateaux et comme ça déjà tu vas
pouvoir te relancer assez vite c'est
très gentil et janvier c'est magnifique
je suis rentré on peut pas
je pense que le lieu va te plaire je
peux pas en parler longtemps mais je
pense que le lieu va te plaire et on
pourra faire des plateaux d'humoriste
c'est quoi une fois par semaine tu vas
faire non bah j'avais fait une fois par
semaine si ça te va moi je suis je suis
ton homme on fera on le fera voilà grand
plaisir
tu sais Fabrice il sait que si je te dis
un truc ah oui moi je non mais Cyril non
il y a un truc dans cette histoire c'est
qu'au fond tout ça aurait pu être évité
ça prouve une chose il paraît de la
confiance et ben ça prouve juste une
chose c'est qu'au fond la confiance
c'est bien mais le juridique c'est pas
si mal bien sûr et que temps en temps
encadrer les relations bah ça évite
ensuite ce genre de truc quoi et que
c'est pas mal au fond d'encadrer des
relations c'est toujours le même débat
Gilles qui a dû bosser sur la faire
c'est que là il y a un vol de marque et
c'est dur à plaider le vol de marque
mais effectivement il a mais si
Géraldine il a il a pris la marque était
lancé totalement et son manager l'a
déposé sans le dire donc maintenant il
faut prouver effectivement que vous
étiez en train de déposer la marque
parce que votre petit erreur entre
guillemets c'est pas avoir déposé avant
lui mais c'est vraiment du vol dire
qu'il a volé le le l'intellectuel il a
volé l'économique et la volé le principe
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
franchement c'est beaucoup pour un seul
homme et de mon point de vue d'après ce
que j'ai vu bâtisse le Caplain est en
tort alors effectivement il se défend
mais pour moi il est vraiment en tort je
pense que vous allez gagner
d'instruction vous allez gagner
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Yassine
ben non je l'écoute attentivement moi
j'espère que vous vous dites quels sont
vos arguments
parlez maintenant non je pense que par
exemple c'est comme si Jamel Debbouze
par exemple portait plainte contre vous
monsieur parce que vous faites un
Comédie Club
il a pris le logo
le logo il a pris les artistes mais non
le logo a pas changé non mais le logo
c'est un signe
distinctifié par rapport
à The Voice on fait Zodio ils ont pris
le truc c'est tout en bémol vous a dit
on aurait pu en parler en plus voilà
mais ils ont changé mais j'ai changé
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a volé batterie
pour qu'elle comprenne bien compris
deux aspects il a volé la marque
effectivement donc au sens juridique du
terme il y a le concept tout ce qui est
attributs de la marque propriété
intellectuel et il y a un deuxième
problème c'est qu'en fait il l'a il lui
a fait miroiter une association etc en
disant voilà on a les échanges moi j'ai
une info qui va calmer tout le monde là
ça y est Géraldine maillet j'espère
qu'elle va comprendre
Yacine a déposé la marque Zodio en 2017
et Lama le manager de le cap plein de la
déposé
the joke Paris en 2022
et donc il en est effectivement
propriétaire mais deuxièmement il y a
quand même ce problème qui pour les
jeunes est important c'est que il y a
quand même un type qui est connu qui dit
je vais m'associer avec toi et à la fin
il récupère le tout ça c'est pas
possible Géraldine
Zodio qui est audio Paris
il y a one more Joe aussi 2017
va faire touche pas à mon écran
de défendre ses amis et c'est toute
façon d'honneur j'aurais fait Paris
voilà ce que c'est pas si clair que ça
mais on les voit tous les éléments moi
je veux dire que moi j'ai des
[Rires]
l'histoire je la connais très bien voilà
il a été payé par exemple
premier mois où il a travaillé par
exemple puisque vous la connaissez bien
l'histoire
je voudrais quand même un moment donné
si vous voulez si vous engagez sur le
terrain des faits on va y aller mais
vraiment on devrait pas parler vas-y
défonceuse qu'est-ce qu'il en résulte
les faits il résulte quoi il résulte des
pièces auxquelles vous n'avez pas accès
auquel j'ai accès que quand même un
moment donné vous avez il a dit non 2017
ensuite quelqu'un qui a déposé en 2022
exploité par lui et en faisant des
échanges bien sûr il vous montre
effectivement que l'objectif on lui dit
c'est toi l'homme clé voilà du
dispositif sans toi ça existe pas mais
sauf que maintenant à l'antenne à
l'antenne dire j'ai des choses que vous
n'avez pas ça c'est pas un argument vous
les avez pas avec vous personne n'est
pas déjà
voilà question très simple moi je suis
pour personne est-ce que quand il vous a
proposé une association vous y êtes allé
parce que seuls les banques vous suivez
pas ou pas pourquoi vous n'êtes pas les
seuls dans l'espace du tout et j'allais
le dire tout à l'heure en fait ces gens
là ça fait 17 ans qui se connaît je
crois son manager à lui et ils auraient
pu le faire tout seul leur salle
pourquoi ils viennent me chercher c'est
moi je leur propose quelque chose ils
acceptent parce que j'ai ce savoir-faire
et j'ai ce carnet d'adresse d'accord
quand tu dis qu'il connaît Baptiste il
connaît pas la nouvelle génération
exactement je sais connais même pas les
nouveaux humoristes voilà c'est moi qui
lui disais ouais lui il est bon elle
elle est pas mal tu le feras chez moi ça
oh mais c'est vrai ouais
moi je vais le faire
ah merde
on est pas bien là
merci merci
Fabrice en tout cas et Yassine on a du
lait en tous les Cyril je suis très
content on va faire des belles chansons